this thing is 15 meters high 20 meters
long it weighs 14 000 tons and contains
enough iron to build two Eiffel towers
and it's absolutely phenomenal
[Music]
but this is the standard model and the
main point about it is it's stupendously
successful so it describes every
measurement we've ever made pretty much
and there was actually a just a result
that came out on Tuesday this week which
is a kind of Flagship you know why the
standard model is brilliant what they
there's a experiment in the United
States where they measure how magnetic
an electron is it's very clever you
basically trap a single electron in a
little sort of a little bottle
effectively and you measure its
magnetism and when you do that you get a
number that you can measure to 12
decimal places so so it's a one part in
a trillion it's incredibly precise
measurement you can use a standard model
to predict how magnetic a muon should be
an electron should be rather and you get
the same number to 12 significant
figures so this is absolutely
unbelievable level of agreement there is
no Theory anywhere in science that comes
anywhere close to being this precisely
sort of verified yet we know this theory
is incomplete and in some sense wrong
because it only describes five percent
of the universe so in this rather
puzzling position
so what we do at CERN is what we're
really trying to do is to find places
where this standard model breaks down
where the particles don't behave in the
way they ought to the way we do this is
using this giant instrument the Large
Hadron Collider so here's a shot of CERN
outside Geneva you can see the the root
of the Large Hadron Collider marked on
the countryside it's 27 kilometers it
starts over here by the airport goes
right round to the Jura mountains you
can see uh Lake Geneva over here and
what it does
um is really quite simple and brutal
essentially it's the sort of most
simple-minded kind of science you can
think of we want to know what the world
is made from so we take little bits of
it we accelerate them to incredibly high
speeds
99.99999 one percent of the speed of
light and then you crash these particles
into each other and what you you're
doing there really is you're actually in
some sense uh creating where you are
creating new forms of matter that
haven't existed since the Big Bang so
this machine is really a machine that
makes particles from energy and that's
why you need to get these things up to
very very high speeds the more energy
you have the heavier the particles you
can make if you go down into the tunnel
this is what you see a very very long
blue tube curving away into the distance
this is the accelerator itself it's
essentially the world's largest and most
expensive thermos flask so um ins this
is actually a cryostat so it's a it's a
vessel that contains superfluid liquid
helium cooled to minus 271 degrees
Celsius the reason it's so cold is
because the way you steer the particles
around the ring are using very powerful
electromagnets and the only way you can
make a magnet powerful enough to bend
these particles traveling at pretty much
the speed of light is if the coils that
make them up are made of a
superconductor this is a material that
has no electrical resistance and that
means you can put huge electric currents
through your magnetic coils and get a
very big magnetic field but this only
works at very low temperatures
um to give you a sense of the challenges
involved with this machine
when you cool something that's 27
kilometers down by 271 degrees well
actually someone probably someone will
answer this question what happens when
you cool a piece of metal down does
anyone know it shrinks so you call it 27
kilometer piece of metal down it shrinks
by 30 meters so this whole machine has
to be able to flex under its own thermal
contraction which is just one of the
incredible things about it and it's
amazing that the engineers who built it
got it to work to be honest
and then this is sort of the business
end of the lhcs this is a photograph of
one of the detectors so at Four Points
around this ring the particles are
brought into collision and what you want
to do when that happens is you want to
image that Collision you want to record
it see what happened the way you do this
is with instruments like this this is
the compact muon solenoid experiment uh
I've always thought it's a strange use
of the word compact
this thing is 15 meters high 20 meters
long it weighs 14 000 tons and contains
enough iron to build two Eiffel towers
and it's absolutely phenomenal you know
it just gives you a sense of scale this
is a person in a hard hat just there and
every part of this is you know the most
precise engineered microelectronics that
can image particles down as sort of
Micron level of precision so it's an
incredibly sophisticated 3D camera
effectively that takes photographs of
the collisions in three dimensions and
it does this 40 million times every
seconds you have collisions 40 million
times a second about nine months of the
year 24 hours a day this is what happens
when you have a collision this is these
are two protons having a very bad day so
they crash into each other the protons
are obliterated and the energy they're
carrying is converted into new particles
so a lot of what you're seeing here are
particles coming flying out that were
created from the energy of that
Collision some of what you're seeing is
the innards of the proton but most of
it's actually new stuff that wasn't
there to start with
you may if you've at all followed the
science news you probably know that 10
years ago CERN achieved its sort of uh
major it actually had its major
achievement which was the discovery of
the Higgs boson and this is um a
photograph from that day the 4th of July
2012. this is as excited as you'll ever
see particle physicists getting
um so yeah there was whooping cheering I
think someone described it as being like
at a football match
I'm not sure they've ever been to an
actual football match but it was it was
certainly pretty Lively by physics
standards anyway and so the discovery of
the Higgs was a big deal I won't go into
that because it's not what the Talk's
about but the story since then really
has been that
what we were hoping for in a way the
Higgs was the last piece of the standard
model that hadn't been found so it was a
bit of unfinished business if you like
from the 20th century what we were
really hoping to find were Dark Matter
particles something that might explain
how matter and antimatter so you know uh
interacted in the early universe but
actually the story of the last 10 years
has really been the fact that we haven't
seen any new particles lots of there was
lots of optimism when I started out as a
PhD student but you know as we've made
more and more measurements with more and
more data nothing has really appeared
and this has left people feeling quite
anxious in general about the future of
fundamental physics because this huge
machine that was supposed to give us all
these answers to these big questions so
far at least hasn't given us many Clues
but what I want to tell you about just
in the last sort of last few minutes of
the talk uh it's about some intriguing
results that we've been getting just in
the last few years that may be hinting
at the beginnings of uh what could be
quite a major breakthrough so um the
first uh set of results came out last uh
march on March 23rd uh last year these
were results from the experiment that I
work on which is called lhcb another one
of the big detectors at cern's there are
four of these and this is one of them it
doesn't look quite as attractive as CMS
it looks a bit more like a multi-colored
tow truck but it's very clever detector
and what this uh detector does is it
studies particles uh called Beauty
quarks so a beauty Quark is there are
six quarks we're made of up and down
quarks and there are four others that
don't exist normally but you can make
them in collider experiments and Beauty
quarks are very interesting because we
can produce them in very large numbers
at the LHC we produce billions and
billions of them every year and that
means you can make very precise
measurements of their properties and one
of the ways that we can look for the
hidden influence of new uh forces for
example is by measuring how these
particles Decay so when they
disintegrate and turn into other things
and then compare that to the
state-of-the-art predictions from our
current theory the standard model so you
have a theoretical prediction you have
an experimental measurement and you
compare them and if they're different if
there's a difference between them that
can indicate that there is something new
that's affecting how these Beauty
particles Decay which can be a clue to
the existence of new forces for example
so um
so as I said yes you can with the known
forces that we already know about we can
say if we imagine this is a beauty Quark
it's green blob and then this yellow
thing and these two red things and some
other particles we can calculate how
often say this process ought to happen
and then see how often it happens
but if there is a new Force let's
imagine there's a fifth force of nature
that we've not seen before that fifth
force can provide an additional route
for the beauty Quark to Decay and that
will subtly change how it decays say how
often it decays or it could also change
the angles that these three particles
come flying out at they might have a
different distribution depending on
what's causing the Decay to happen the
particularly exciting result that came
out in March was essentially doing
something quite simple where you take
some beauty quarks and you look at their
Decay where they turn into something
called a strange Quark which is the next
lightest one and then an electron and an
anti-electron the main thing is to
notice there's some electrons here okay
that's the key thing and then we do we
look at another Decay where you switch
the electrons for muons now if you
remember I said that muons are like
copies of the electron they're just
heavier they're 200 times heavier but in
all other ways they're identical and
because they're identical the forces of
nature treat them the same so we expect
the beauty Quark to Decay into electrons
equally as a often as it decays into
muons so a very good test of the
standard model is just to count how many
of these things we see how many of these
things we see and see if they're the
same and if they're not the same that
could indicate a new Force because
there's nothing in the standard model
that can change can make a difference
essentially between these two sets of
particles
um and indeed that's what we found so we
found my colleagues found last March um
effectively that there is a there seems
to be a difference between how often
these processes are happening and it's
at a statistical significance which
means that there is about a one in a
thousand chance that this result is a
fluke
um so it's a little bit like imagine
your
trying to figure out if a coin is a is a
Fair coin so you toss that coin
repeatedly let's say you could toss it
ten times
this equivalent to getting 10 heads in a
row so I think if you had a coin you
tossed it 10 times you've got 10 heads
you think this coin is probably a bit
dodgy
um but the problem with particle physics
is we don't just toss one coin 10 times
we're tossing thousands of coins many
many times so you expect when you do
lots of measurements some of them to
sort of deviate from your theory some of
them just by random chance so we're not
yet at the threshold where we can say
for sure that this is a real effect but
it's definitely getting really quite
interesting and could be indicating this
is the first sort of imprint of a new
Force the other thing that makes this
quite exciting is that about literally
uh you know you had no new physics for
10 years and then two come along like
buses within the space of about a month
of each other another result from an
experiment in America in Fermi lab where
they measured the magnetism of the muon
so the same part is muon again the same
Troublesome particle and this is an
experiment just near Chicago uh just I
was actually there in July very
impressive piece of Kit go and see it if
you can this is what it looks like it's
a big ring so basically what they're not
quite as big as the LHC this is the sort
of you can see some people here so it's
not 27 kilometers long but it's still
very impressive and what they do is they
send muons around this ring and as they
go around the ring they measure how
magnetic they are
um and what they found is that the again
just like the electron
the muon has a magnetic field and you
can calculate how strong the magnetism
of the muon should be from the known
laws of physics from the known
ingredients of our universe and what
they found when they measured this is
these two numbers were different again
the MU one was slightly more magnetic
than it ought to be and this time the
statistical significance meant there's
about a one in forty thousand chance of
this being a fluke so this is a bit like
tossing 15 heads in a row so
spectacularly unlikely so it's starting
to look like potentially there's
something really interesting going on
here and the fact that both of these
measurements involve these weird muon
things suggest there may be a common
explanation perhaps involving a new
force of nature so yeah it's a really
exciting moment we've we've got these
big Mysteries that we don't understand
we don't know what most the universe is
made from we don't know how we exist we
don't know why we exist and we've been
spent we've spent much of the last 50
years trying to get some crack some clue
that will lead us into the next sort of
stage of development where we will
actually start to be able to answer
these questions and these anomalies are
still very uncertain it's not really
clear which way they're going to go
there is a part there's always a
possibility with these sorts of
measurements there's some mistake in the
experiment or maybe even a mistake in
your theoretical calculation there's a
famous example of this from a few years
ago where someone missed a minus signs
like a classic school school child error
and that actually we thought there was a
normally but there wasn't it was just a
stray minus sign we don't think there
are mistakes like that in this case and
the fact they're all sort of lining up
with each other is rather intriguing if
it does turn out to be true it's going
to be the biggest breakthrough I think
in fundamental physics for the best part
of two or three decades it will really
be the start of a New Journey of
Discovery because it's very unlikely
that if there is a new particle out
there or a new force that it's on its
own it's probably part of a much larger
family that will be connected
potentially to the mystery of dark
matter or to the origins of matter in
the very early Universe
um but we'll have to wait and see we
should get more data and more results in
the in the near future in the next few
years so this puzzle will be hopefully
resolved one way or another but if you
found this interesting keep your eyes
peeled on the sort of science press
because we may be on the brink of a
really exciting moment in our
understanding of the universe thanks
very much for your attention
[Applause]
the podcast talks debates courses and
articles visit the Institute of Art and
ideas click the link on screen now to
IAI dot TV